qui est pour lui la plus belle fille
voilà de france wen rico je vous laisse
réfléchir c'est qui pour vous la plus
belle fille de france vous c'est calme à
ses bons sa maman bah c'est beau ça va
causer mignan où c'est qui moi si leïla
bekhti j'ai trop subi et la bêtise c'est
leïla leïla bekhti oui mais voilà elle
est belle elle est intelligente elle est
gracieuse elle est adorable a tout pour
elle a pas mal bossé qui vont moi j'aime
beaucoup cécile de france c'est une
belle femme un peu fabre n'a pas la
photo laisse en train de chercher là ils
sont en train de taper de france ils ont
tous les chefs de tribu
c'est bon de leur dire cela les belles
d'accord ouais d'accord des deux là
c'est pas mon désir pressant mais si je
les aime beaucoup
là il va non plus ça n'est pas personne
et mon délire oui la mienne ça va être
votre délire caroline de maigret
le top model français même pas qui c'est
mais bon un femme de yao mais grecque
avec le pic la ruine de maigret oui et
non
allez une petite habitude non l'égérie
d'une plus grande marque de maïs très
joli mais c'est pas mon délire j'adore
c'est la femme la plus jolie mais c'est
la faute aux pas mon délire ça n'est pas
mon délire à moi c'est les amours de
proximité ce sera ça reste ça reste
chaude toujours toujours sa moustache je
sais gérer d'une manière on avait bouffé
la moustache car non mais elle me gêne
géraldine qui est de plus en plus belle
des manières
mais ça n'est pas monté bien mais elle
est manipulée ça n'est pas bon dire oui
bon pour moi c'est qu'il y met et anne
sinclair a dévié aussi un organe
sinclair pour le fond et la forme
un banal a pas du tout mon délire mais
pas du tout vous dire il approuve ou
l'avez pas me jean-louis dis-moi dix
mots que j'avais choisi ce que des
photos où elles sont les coudes et
belmont oui non mais sans rigoler c'est
pas possible on voit le guette bonne
forme à laon me dise et les photos les
moins chers
si c'est les moins chers bravo oui vous
c'est qu'il n'y en a qu'une c'est fatou
elle est très belle mais arrête de faire
le bouffon sans minerai de fer le cas
d'arrêt de la bavaroise
alors je vous raconte escale a fait
jeudi ce qu'il a fait la semaine
dernière il va raconter lui même qu'est
ce qu'il appelle week-end dernier
sarr est et ce qu'il appelle week-end
dernier et sound dernier j'ai fait une
petite soirée pensions sont vers des
attentions et quoi je sais ce n'est pas
tout elle au resto avec des copines
oui n'était pas vous n'étiez pas non
mais il est arrivé pourquoi la mission
mais non ce n'est rien non c'était
quelques jours avant mais oui bah oui
mais c'est gentil j'arrive comme ça déjà
ne m'accepte avec vous dînez j'arrive
vous m'accepter alors n'aurait pas ce
qu'il adore faire ça ah oui pour le
taulier we will hayes alors merci
monsieur le flunch combien c'est vrai ou
pas avec les chantiers c'est vrai c'est
vrai ce dîner avec fatou hier oui
absolument
ou tête à tête elle a accepté c'est vrai
oui mais paraît que ça marche c'est
normal si ta meuf est pas mon jour s'est
prêtée avec dont on conçoit des bonnes
questions très content voilà vous c'est
qui la plus belle femme vivante souple
et encore moi c'est une allemagne le roi
et que j'aime bien je vous adore nolwenn
alors c'est pas mon délire c'est comme
ma soeur c'est comme ma soeur mais
j'aime beaucoup
ah ouais poussée qui alors en sommes
c'est tunisien mais enfin ma femme
madame c'est moi ou ça vous savez on
s'appelle tous les jours et rôle de plus
en plus proche c'est vrai ou pas alors
ça pas toujours mais on est de moins en
moins proche
mais enfin mais j'espère qu'il ne
pardonnera enfin je suis très très très
nordique et je suis très salée on va
voir c'est lui ressemble alors c'est un
nom et je suis très sincères de ma
réponse si c'est kelly ont cependant je
trouve que c'est la fille la plus jolie
c'est pas la même je suis absolument
d'accord
non mais n'a pas les mêmes cheveux et ça
fait trop plaisir antoine est magnifique
et ben ça s est passé près mais votre s
armani finale est le dernier rendez vous
que vous avez eu chez l'ophtalmo je
rigole trop méchant c'est qu'elle est
belle arrêté je charrie c'est bon allez
on joue pas non mélangés pour sa part à
bordères allait le faire un bisou
[Applaudissements]
devant fonctionnent pas très quoi ça
fait plaisir la kiffer et plus la peine
aussi c'est qu'ils pour vous bah oui
laetitia casta
ah ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais donc
j'adorerais mais je sais par mon des
jolies photos d'hier de tout le monde me
dit pas un camion à ces murmures quoi
moi y'en a une qui est en train de
chauffer de fou c'est brune poirson
l'écologie on se calme heureux d'être en
demies on va se passer un truc à laval
avait dit qu'elle attaquerait le gars
facile payait pas ses produits un vent d
invendus des amendes l'aladi ce matin
tous les grands restaurants qui font pas
le tri des déchets des amendes ou dans
quinze jours à lévis tellement vous êtes
menacé mon équipe est en train de tomber
amoureux ville de jouf dit je vous ai
jamais douté était pas la cfdt y cieux
non mais tu te descendre non mais alors
que j'adore elle est belle très belle
saison et ça n'est pas bon dans le nom
marie pour tous là nous ce qui vous je
crois que c'est adele est ce exact
alors c'est pas mon délire c'est pas mon
délire mais j'aime bien et toi enrico ts
que thain et c'est une femme de mon pays
tant à djamila tata jadida
s'il est content mais j'ai dit c'est
qu'il fait bien la semoule
[Musique]
c'est l'emploi maurice et pas bouffer
des responsables à huy brigitte bardot
ah oui elle était attirée s'est pas vu
depuis longtemps mais très bonne mais ça
n'est pas né benoît et bien vous si rim
vous n'allez pas d'élire mais vous allez
forcément du goût quand même un peu non
alors on m'a jamais parlé comme ça